mentioned earlier the trump campaign
says it plans to file a federal lawsuit
against the state of nevada and clark
county
they claim widespread voter fraud and
they want the counting
stopped hector mejia is live with more
details on that hector
well the trump campaign made that
announcement right in front of the clark
county election department just feet
away from mail ballots are still being
counted
republicans claim that clark county is
illegally counting some mail ballots but
they did not present any evidence that
widespread voter fraud is happening here
in our county
and when pressed for evidence the trump
campaign said
they'd release more after the lawsuit
gets filed in federal district court
here in las vegas
campaign officials want a judge to order
clark county to stop
counting and here's the reasoning
republicans claim that roughly 10
thousand people who voted no longer live
in nevada
the trump campaign accuses clark county
of counting the votes of dead people
and the count the votes of people who
moved out of nevada during the pandemic
but they did not provide specific
examples of either
adam laxalt co-chair for the trump
campaign in nevada says
they want to have oversight we were told
that signatures
would save us from all fraud but to date
we still have not been able to observe
these signatures or or meaningfully
challenge
a single male invalid out of hundreds of
thousands of
casts we firmly believe that there are
many voters in this group of mail-in
people
that are not proper voters
we are down to the wire two days after
the election and nevada is one of the
few states still counting ballots
our state's six electoral votes could be
what determines the outcome of the
presidency
the county did respond to the trump
campaign's claim by saying
they are not aware of any improper
ballots being counted
that's latest that's the latest from
north las vegas hector mejia
8 news now all right hector thanks very
much we have